this is a talk about digitally driven
manufacturing which is something we've
spent the last roughly seven years at
buttonsmith coming up on eight
uh working on
um
i i need to open with a with a
disclosure and maybe a disclaimer
because we're in the middle of a reg cf
public offering
so there are a lot of things i'm going
to say that are opinions of mine or
forward-looking statements and of course
some are going to turn out to be wrong
and others will be superseded or refined
and some of them may not happen at all
so you know there we are with the with
the qualifiers um
and all of all of the people you know i
i can see at least know that but uh who
knows who who will watch this thing
after the fact so
being as how this is a a university
class we have to start with a multiple
guess question
so what is a button smith
and the possibilities here are someone
who makes buttons a name you will keep
until your current race is done
a software company that is automating
digital production or a light
manufacturer which by the way is what
crunchbase and pitchbook thinks the
answer is
we are in fact a software company that
is automating digital production
we set up a production facility because
if you want to do that successfully you
have to know how it actually works
and that prototype manufacturing
facility has been paying for our
software team so i suppose we're doing
something vaguely right
and it's amazing because we present to
the world as a manufacturer but in fact
were accompanied by software people
[Music]
so this is not really a tech talk in the
in the tradition of ee 380 right i mean
e380 is about
processor architecture and microkernels
and internet worms and you know modular
assembly robotics and cool technical
stuff dennis that last one is a future
promise for you
and these are all things where we're
talking about activities where the gross
margins and these activities in the
mature companies run about 75 to 85
percent
um as the gross margins right
this is a talk about reimagining
manufacturing
and so i'm going to talk about what are
the assumptions around the problem that
are getting in the way what are the
possible
solutions
um what are the
economic and commercial systems and
environment look like
um
and manufacturing is an activity where
the gross margins today are in the seven
percent range and
step back and think about yourself as an
investor and ask yourself
if you get to invest in something with a
seven percent return or something with
an 85 return which way are you likely to
go
um and while i gather that forest basket
may be doing some investment in this
area um by and large if vcs tell you
that there's investment going into
manufacturing first it's not coming from
them and second it's probably not
happening at all because economically it
doesn't make a lot of sense
um
where we're trying to we're trying to
move this needle and we're trying to get
it to and i think we have a reasonable
chance
uh is to get manufacturing to something
with gross margins in the 30 range range
while reducing consumer prices on the
resulting products by
potentially a factor of five and i'll
get back to how we do that
and also providing higher revenue to the
producer because if the customers are
buying products that they already know
they want
they actually will pay more for those
problems
it is very much not in the
incremental
you know agile methods sort of approach
there's a lot that has to be built to
make this work and we have in fact built
it one step at a time working from the
customer back
but if you
start from
manually set type and you take an
incremental approach right what you end
up with
is the culmination of over 100 years of
refinement and development by heidelberg
it is probably one of the fastest
platinum presses ever produced for
letterpress printing
while many other platinum presses feed
the paper with the same motion that it
is delivered the windmill had two arms
that one could be feeding the paper and
the other delivering paper
thus making the press nearly twice as
fast as other plastic vessels
so as it happens we actually have three
of these machines we've taken them off
of our floor because they're far too
dangerous to operate
but if you're if you're looking for a
mental pigeon hole to put the heidelberg
in right this is what the xerox press
looks like in 1938 it's capable of doing
4 000 to 5 000 impressions an hour
depending on which version of this
you're doing
the catch is
all of those things have to be printed
with the same thing right because you're
putting a plate in the machine and it's
a letterpress printer it's a plate
printer
depending on which version you're
looking at you're looking at a seven ton
press right running at 4 000 operations
now or do not put your hands near there
and that's why we're not running them
um
of course
that kind of incremental approach right
will not get you to something like an hp
indigo which is the thing at the bottom
right i mean to get to an hp indigo you
actually have to reimagine
what printing is about what composition
is about you need some form of computer
in this picture you need some form of
typesetting in this picture in the
software sense right there's a whole
ecosystem that has to be built uh to
make a machine like an indigo make any
sense or a xerox press or take your pack
when the indigo just happens to be the
latest shiniest toy in this particular
space
um and what we're doing is very
definitely in the disruptive camp uh
we've been told by approximately
everybody in the venture investment
world up here in seattle that we should
you know find a more contained problem
and
the problem with hard things is their
heart um the good news is we we seem to
be succeeding at it
so
okay
so why should we care about fixing
manufacturing and the part of the answer
is
it's a strategic issue right one of the
things that i think we've learned in the
last two two and a half years
is that there's no meaningful economic
security without a viable manufacturing
sector there's no meaningful national
security without a viable manufacturing
sector right we went into a world where
we needed masks we largely depended on
china to produce them and what we got
was counterfeits
right and some of that was just the
usual
thing from chinese producers cutting
corners and you know shaving the edges
but some of it wasn't right we also saw
active marketing attacks on u.s sellers
who were selling legitimate masks right
this was not pretty
um and that's not the kind of dependency
structure we want to be in
when we're looking at a national crisis
there's nothing new about this we've
been talking about this in chip
fabrication for at least two decades
that i know about probably longer
um
having dependencies on people whose
interests are not necessarily aligned
with yours is problematic and the
manufacturing sector is one of the big
places where we have an issue
but another reason is
right we have a problem
if you look at growth in the u.s
manufacturing sector you discover that
it's two percent a year
and that number goes back pretty
consistently 10 1970 which is when cargo
containers come into the picture right
and with the arrival of cargo containers
what you start seeing in manufacturing
is
some class of products start struggling
right it falls out of u.s production its
production moves to china where labor
costs are lower the reason we're
sustaining this two percent growth is
that other products come into the fold
and start getting manufactured right and
then progressively they start to fall
out of the system so this is not a story
about the successive manufacturing this
is a story about kind of eating our seed
corn um in this steady state number i
mean this isn't growth in any meaningful
sense of the term
um and the reason that matters is the
story in china looks very different
they've been seeing 13.6 growth annually
since
2010 or 2011 depending on where you want
to draw the line
and that means they're going six times
faster than we are and that's not a
sustainable position for the united
states it's not a sustainable position
for a lot of other countries we just
happen to be telling a u.s story this
week
but as if that wasn't enough
in the last 10 years we've lost 30
percent of the head count
in u.s manufacturing
that's not a manufacturing problem
that's a structure of society problem
right we're at the point where the
disparity of wealth in the united states
at least historically
is a dangerous signal for for revolution
and i'm not suggesting that we're going
to have a revolution this week or next
week i don't know if we're going to have
a revolution
at all but it's not at all ambiguous
that we have an enormous part of the
problem for the population that's
tremendously disaffected and feeling
disenfranchised i think i think we
proved that in january
we're in a risky place and part of it is
that in losing manufacturing we
undermine the middle class and the
middle class is necessary the
functioning of our society
and by the way the employment levels
that we're seeing in manufacturing right
now
have not been seen in manufacturing
since october of 1945.
this is kind of crazy
um so i think that there is a societal
issue here of how do we
restore a balanced society and i think
this is not all of the problem by any
means not all of the solution by any
means but it's it's part of what we need
to do
all right
there's an existential issue here right
mass production
means that you're producing products
long before you have a customer and long
before you can really assess what the
customers in a bulk sense actually want
and the output of that process means
that 30 percent of mass-produced
consumer products never find a customer
right they get destroyed they get given
away they end up in landfills in the
fashion industry it's worth the number
there is is worse the number there is
closer to 50
and in the high fashion industry it can
be almost 90
and the reason for this basically is
that there's no customer at the time the
product is being made you don't actually
know what the customer wants yet and we
as purchasers are paying for all of this
waste right it's not like these products
that get thrown away
disappear the cost of them gets baked
into the products that do get sold
it's an existential issue in a different
sense right china produces more
greenhouse gases than all of the oecd
and eu countries combined
and more than 60 percent of that is
directly or indirectly
attributable to manufacturing
it doesn't seem to me
that relying on china to do our
manufacturing is necessarily a place
that we want to be if we want to be able
to breathe 10 years from now
we got stuck here
in 1970 right we we started this process
in mass production circa 1910 1920
depending on who you want to give credit
for
uh credit to
um and we've stuck with what's been
succeeding but in 1970 it stopped
succeeding
very subtly very slow loading rate but
that's when the dominance started
falling on mass production and we have
been banging our head against the same
wall looking for different results for
the last 50 years and that's not a good
experiment at a certain point you have
to realize the experiment is failing
and
part of what's going on is we have
assumptions about what's feasible in
manufacturing that no longer hold
because the tools that we have to do
manufacturing with have changed
um
and this is you know this is the classic
what you know that ain't so because the
conditions have changed of course
the things that you don't know are good
for plenty of mistakes too so we've got
to watch out for these it's always
cheaper to learn from other people's
mistakes if you if you have the
opportunity to do that
um so here's what we assume
in most of the manufacturing world is is
possible right
at one extreme we have what might be
characterized as artisan production
right we have people who can do lots and
lots of different things
right
but they're not doing very many of them
right so high mix low volume sort of
environment
and that ranges from
your local bakery to you know anybody
who's producing anything by hand or
anything who's anybody who's producing
something custom one at a time that's
involved to to produce and is not being
done digitally
at the other extreme in the spectrum we
have classical mass mass production
right which we've been doing for more
than 100 years right you can get as many
as you want so long as they're black
nowadays we can even give you other
colors that that was an interesting
refinement along the way
and we've made some move in the lean
production world to improving our
ability to do mixes
in this process along with a lot of
other improvements right this is the
toyota production system right this is
how toyota beat the american car
industry
um i'm going to keep out of the yellow
box here mostly for for my amusement
because it was late when i was doing the
slides but it's a little off topic for
manufacturing
um
here's what we can do today
right
with digital manufacturing tools right
we don't have to do the same item at
each
cycle as we go through the production
process and that means we have a whole
portfolio of options ranging from doing
mass production right to doing one-off
production all of that stuff is on the
table and that gives us tremendous
options
for how we approach production
um
and i'll get into why that's possible
so when we talk about digitally driven
production right what i'm thinking about
when i talk about this is
a production model where
we're going to make what the customer
actually wants in the quantity that they
want right don't don't don't tell me
i've gone to bic and i want printed pens
but i can only buy them by the 100.
right
without specialized customer expertise
right you see a lot of discussions in
this space that start with send me a cad
file and i'll come back to where that's
kind of ridiculous but whether it's
ridiculous or not most customers don't
know how to generate cad files this is
not a business model in a scalable sense
we want to do this on demand right i
don't want to make anything until the
customers already paid for it and very
clearly told me that they want it by
paying for it
otherwise i'm taking a production risk
and that's actually what we're doing
with the mass production and we're doing
it a grand scale
we want to produce this at a lower price
and i'll talk about how we think we can
get there
we want to do it at higher margins and
that's about giving the customer what
they actually wanted and knowing that we
did so
and frankly not flooding the market with
the same product over and over again
uh the goal is to do it locally because
we want to reduce transportation steps
and i'll get back to that
and hopefully we can do all of this
without destroying the planet and we at
least actually believe that's possible
it's going to involve major changes this
is not not easy
why is this conceptually hard to do why
if i'm a manufacturer it is all is it
almost impossible for me to get from
where i'm standing
um to doing this type of what we're
describing is as digitally driven
production
um
so first we're not just talking about
additive or subtractive manufacturing
right jeff wilke is pumping enormous
amounts of money into that apparently
doing great work
and 3d printers and cnc milling and
things like that are definitely a piece
of this problem right but these are
you know machines that do a particular
function in a larger ecosystem that has
to be connected right
if we're actually going to do
single page production
it involves changes in how we think
about product design because we need to
be able to do variations and those
variations need to be part of the design
process up front they can't be arbitrary
variations if we're going to do them
successfully
we need to think about listings and i'll
come to that in a second right we need
to think about how sales work this is
mostly a direct to customer or direct to
business sort of a production strategy
right that changes our distribution
structures that's going to take us back
to
transportation it's going to change the
way we order things because if you walk
into a local print shop and say i want
to print a wedding invitation 30 of the
labor cost for the printer goes into
extracting from your head that thing
that you're not quite able to describe
this thing you want them to produce for
you right that's an enormous cost if
you're only going to make one we need a
better way to think about that
we need to change the production
management so that as we're making those
one and they're going across the floor
when they come at the end of the
production floor we know which one's
going to who
and if one manages to drop somewhere in
the process we know which one has to be
recovered and who it's going to after
it's recovered
and of course the fulfillment strategy
changes because instead of sending a
truck with 60 pallets of one thing
i i'm sending a truck of
fedex envelopes right each of which is
going to a different address that
changes how i think about doing
fulfillment
um changes the cost of fulfillment
none of these things that i'm describing
with the possible exception of the
production itself although i would say
mostly not for single piece production
none of these things are core
competencies for manufacturers right
this can't happen by magic in the
existing manufacturing ecosystem
and
for the most part there certainly are
some exceptions
manufacturers in the united states and
in most of the world have relatively
little capital
that they're operating on very low
margins they're largely debt funded
right they're borrowing in order to buy
parts to produce products
they
don't have the wherewithal to do this
without some outside help which is why
buttonsmith exists we're trying to put
together the software infrastructure
to make this sort of thing possible
flexibility is not something that i
think of as one of the founding
principles of manufacturing today right
in software we totally take it for
granted that we're going to build
general purpose software it's going to
have a whole bunch of applications and
we're going to invent more as we go
largely without changing the software
right then the software will evolve and
it will chase us into these new
applications but fundamentally we don't
think about building software
outside of the embedded space for some
narrowly defined single turbines that's
totally how we think about doing
manufacturing equipment
um
and there are companies out there that
are starting to poke at this bright
machines has done some interesting work
although
i think there's much to be learned from
what they did
and then after you get through all of
that right there's this belief that
china has already won so what's the
point
and so if we're going to actually
move manufacturing into a sustainable
value proposition that can be executed
in the united states and if we think
that china has won the game already then
what we got to do is change the game
and the beautiful thing about low volume
production is you can't do it cost
effectively from the other side of the
ocean
because you can't take five things and
shove them in a cargo container and sell
them to me at any rational price it
doesn't work
and there's no way that's ever going to
be possible for beijing especially now
that we've stopped subsidizing china
post
but all of this requires a very
different way of thinking about the
problem
and the very hardest part of this
as in any major change why isn't mindset
right
how do i think about this as an
end-to-end problem there's this
ubiquitous issue that manufacturers will
buy some big piece of equipment that
gets sold on it maybe it's a great piece
of equipment
maybe it does whatever it does 10 times
faster than the previous piece of
equipment but that's only helpful if the
rest of the process after that machine
is prepared to accept input 10 times
faster
if it's not
all you've bought is a really sexy
machine that's not actually moving the
ball forward for you because you can
only go as fast as the steps to come
after that machine
and
you see this happening all the time
there's a mindset that
i can't do it right i don't have the
cash flow i don't have the free cash to
invest and i don't understand how
e-commerce works right i don't
understand customers because i don't
talk to them right there's a view that
it's always been this way and it doesn't
have to change we see that in everything
there's a need to talk to end customers
how many manufacturers actually speak
directly to customers
and the answer is almost none of them
right maybe they talk to walmart but
walmart isn't the end customer for the
product and for walmart we can name lots
of lots of potential companies right but
there's almost no feedback loop from the
end customer back to the manufacturer
other than how many of them actually got
sold right but that's not very detailed
information
um
and the people in the middle the
distributors uh the middlemen in in the
wholesaling world right they think the
customers are their property they're not
eager to put the manufacturer in touch
with the customers they want to be an
information bottleneck right because
this is about lock-in
we need to think about turnaround types
differently if you go to a large
promotional producer with a large order
they're going to say you know you'll
have your 1500 lanyards for the next use
next conference in six weeks eight weeks
something like this right
that needs to be done tomorrow
especially if we're talking about low
quantities right people aren't going to
come and say
you know i'm going to order my lanyard
or my or my hat or whatever it is i'm
ordering and it's okay if it gets to me
in six weeks six weeks is forever amazon
has invested millions of dollars in
teaching people something they already
basically had which was a desire for
instant satisfaction they've done that
very very effectively that's actually an
advantage
if we look at it the right way but it's
a challenge it requires thinking
differently
and the distribution model changes
entirely because if i'm producing on
demand i don't need distributors for
finished goods right that's a big red
flag because my distributors aren't
going to like that
right now if i'm a mass producer
right i design a product or i work with
somebody to get a product design and the
next step is i build a whole bunch of
them and i push them into the market and
i hope like hell that they sell and
sometimes they don't
right
we have to work from the customer back
right we have to ask what does the
customer actually want how are we going
to produce that as opposed to
we've produced this thing how we're
going to convince the customer to buy it
right this is a total 180 on how to
think about sales
and and that's what i mean by this pull
nut push notion i'm borrowing lead
terminology here
we also need to think about how
production flow works right now i build
a huge pile of stuff and then i move it
on to the next station and it tries to
consume this huge pile of stuff that's
that's crazy right i built a pile i took
the pile apart that was totally wasted
effort what i wanted was a floor where
everything flowed smoothly and as each
unit came out of a stage it's ready to
go into the next stage the next stage is
ready to take it if i've got a pile
accumulating somewhere i haven't
designed my floor correctly
right and that's not the way
manufacturers mostly think about this
problem and i'm making very general
statements about manufacturers there are
definitely exceptions to these
statements i'm sort of speaking broadly
about how people in this world think
we think about finished inventory um
in many manufacturing contexts as an
asset right we want to send stuff to
distributors and the distributors buffer
us
from the changes in demand variations in
our end customers right and we think
that's good
but what that's actually is this is an
exposure because every one of those
things sitting in distributor inventory
is at risk of never being sold
right i've made it ahead of sales
and that's not a good model and if
you've looked at um
[Music]
the
sort of classroom studies that are done
at the major business goals one of the
fun games that you'll see is something
called the beer game and it's how you go
out of business as a beer producer by
committing the sin of producing a new
successful craft beer
and
you go out of business
because the distribution hierarchy
creates enough latency
that by the time you realize people are
running with your beer and drinking it
like crazy and taking off and you need
to build more right by the time you find
that out you have to stand up another
production facility and by the time you
get the production facility done the
customers have moved on to the next beer
and now you can't pay for it
so this kind of buffering is actually an
exposure it's not an asset
this isn't just an issue for the
manufacturer from a standpoint of
product risk it's also an issue from a
standpoint of lending if you go to a
lender and you want working capital one
of the things you're going to look to
collateralize it on is your inventory
but your inventory is a risk that's the
last thing you want to collateralize on
mindset
to an incumbent
these issues are well beyond terrifying
right they mean totally rethinking the
business that you're in and that's
always hard
as a producer if you decide you want to
do this right you don't get to shut down
any of what you're doing today and say
i'm going to take a month off and i'm
going to figure out how to deploy this
stuff which by the way i'm not going to
get right the first time because there's
learning curve
right and i'm going to switch gears
right you don't actually get to do that
right you have to keep making money
while you're doing this which means
you're in two camps in your head at once
um we're in the middle of actually
moving our production floor from one
location to another we're not changing
how we're doing things but we don't get
to shut down production really to do it
merely moving stuff in this way is a
nightmare if i were trying to change our
production strategy at the same time
um i'm not sure what i would be turning
to for solace but i'm sure my wife
wouldn't approve
um and if you do this if you admit that
you're doing this that you're starting
to think about selling things directly
to customers what happens is in many
sectors your distributors blackball you
right and then your revenue disappears
and then you don't have any money to pay
for all this this is a this is a real
challenge right you're kind of a pig and
a poke if you want to do this
and it's hard
but it's not optional
because there's no meaningful market for
handset type today right we have to move
on and moving to the heidelberg windmill
press which in 1938 was miraculous is
not miraculous in 2020.
there's also no market for buggy whips
well okay there is but it's not the
market that we cared about
there are technical challenges in this
process right as if the concept issues
weren't enough
their whole horde of technical issues
right
we need to reduce labor per unit
and
we'd like to apply automation to that
but the state of the world in robotics
is about where we were when building
basic for the you know mits altair 8800
right that's that's where we are we
don't have huge piles of software
infrastructure we don't have notions of
modularity in automation by and large
and there's a hardware issue and there's
a software issue and then there's a
process issue and all of those things
have to modularize in compatible ways
for this to work
in in many cases we don't have good
material handling solutions one of the
reasons that we don't have fully
automated cut and sew
is it turns out that handling of fabric
is really hard if you talk to people
doing robotics right notice that all the
things they want to talk about are rigid
even just putting tape on something
right if it's not a rigid material find
a tape machine that can apply a strip of
tape to that product right and there is
one ring is done with a clamp and a
robot arm but it's not a traditional
taping machine
we can't deal with things that are shiny
that tends to break a lot of the vision
tools that we would like to use in
robotics we have similar issues with
things that are clear
um so there's this whole class of things
that are kind of
we haven't gotten to yet is is the
charitable way to put it some of which
are very very uh very high value items
right being able to change the way
garments are built there's a lot of
money there but it's a hard problem
um
in the midst of all of that the assembly
issue
tends to get ignored
there are parts of assembly that we
don't actually know how to automate for
starters almost anything involving
selling
that becomes the bottleneck right and
people
forget as they're working their way
through this big complex problem that
the labor time in assembly is actually
the big cost in all of this
maybe labor and shipping if you're
really shipping one at a time
but those are the two costs nothing else
actually really matters in any of this
it's not it's not very big in your cost
of goods
how do i approach
production
thinking about it as if i get a 10 000
unit order i'm going to produce 10 000
single items and then i'm going to put
them in the same box
instead of i'm going to do 10 000 copies
of something
and the reason i want to think about it
that way is i want the flexibility not
to care if it's ten thousand ones or one
thousand ones or a hundred ones i don't
wanna change my process to do that
and i also don't wanna have to get into
a job shop scheduling problem to
navigate around this 10 000 piece order
right if i get a single piece order in
the middle of that it's not clear that i
want to run to the end of the 10 000
piece order before i go deal with the
single piece order and there's no reason
why i shouldn't be able to sort of
cuisinart these things together
if that's advantageous in serving my
customers
that's a change in the way we think
about production because we get to
divide jobs
and that's something we don't get to do
in a mass production for today for the
most part
how do we do
product designs that are parameterizable
how do we make it possible for customers
to choose variants for customers to
choose variations on what they want made
in a way that's approachable from a user
experience perspective
and then when it's all done can be
turned directly into something where i
can send it to the machine that's
actually going to do the production and
i i'm sending it digitally in production
ready form right there's a whole set of
technology issues getting from the
listing to the user going through the
customization experience to getting this
thing produced and
if what you're trying to do is get an
image on a t-shirt there are lots and
lots of pieces of software out there
that will do that but that turns out to
be
relative to the rest of the space
um
kind of an embarrassingly easy problem
right if you try to do this for any more
general customization you'll find that
it's quite hard
and i should be clear that we're not
necessarily just talking about i'm a
customer and i want my slogan or my name
on my product right we could also be
talking about a small retailer who wants
branding on things for their four or
five stores right or we could be talking
about things that aren't in any way
modified for the customer we can do all
of those things with this kind of
technology
um
how do we do listings at scale that one
turns out to be brutal and i'm going to
come back to that one in a minute
we have equipment
that first equipment that exists right
is all more and more intended to serve
well it's mostly intended to serve the
people who want to do thousands of
things if you want to buy a wide format
printer to produce 4 000 miles of
wallpaper
efi has the product for you
right if you need six inches of print
because you're doing one lanyard it is
totally not the right solution for you
right so how do we get that solution how
do we how do we get equipment that
serves this model instead of the bolt
model but also doesn't give up
how do we get the software to do it
the integrators are focused on the wrong
term we're talking to robotics
integrators at the moment and one of the
things we've realized is by the time
we're done getting it into their heads
that we're trying to automate single
piece production we could have done the
integration ourselves
which is what we're gonna end up doing
um
and all of this stuff is going on in
silos right people have this idea that
they're focused on on one machine right
um esco has some fantastic printing and
cutting technology and their notion is
that if there's a robot involved that's
gonna it's gonna feed material under
their machine they're gonna they're
gonna run the print on their machine and
they're gonna palletize the result
gather it up onto a pallet then you're
going to take the pallet and move it to
the next cell
and and for esco we could drop 15
different printers into that steven
right
but that's actually not what we want
what we want is flow right you want that
thing to come off of that printer and
move directly into the next step of
production
putting into a pallet is pure waste
and that's not the mindset coming from
the vendors
and if you try to talk to them about
getting access to the information you
need in order to do that sort of
integration
it's possible but um
it's definitely an interesting exercise
there's a there's a trust building
process that has to happen because they
view that stuff as tightly held
partly because it's an opportunity for
the customer to really have a bad
outcome with their equipment
and they're concerned about that and the
right to be concerned
and then you know down at the nuts and
bolts layer
we have
i don't know 10 different major vendors
producing robots
that you can buy here in the states uh
at this sort of small production
interior um
every one of which has a different
operating model and a different
programming language from the last one
some of them are more capable than
others some of them forgot little things
like recursion
or sub subroutines
in the way that we think of it now
and
sometimes the robot you want isn't from
the same vendor you purchased from last
time
and even if it were
that robot now has to operate in an
environment where
it's taking something from one machine
it's doing robotic function it's putting
the result into some next stage process
it's not just about programming the
robot it's about having the robot engage
with the machines around it we don't
have a good platform to stand on to do
this kind of integration
the the work on robot operating system
looks interesting
but it's far from near you
and then the process challenges
one of the things that's just brutal
about doing single piece production
if you if you watch a manufacturing
floor you will see a whole bunch of
scenarios where somebody is walking
around with a bin or they're pushing a
cart
and in this bin they're 100 or a
thousand items
and the five minutes that that person
takes walking across the floor
divided out over the thousand items
sure you'd like to get rid of it but
it's not your biggest problem mostly
that labor that five minutes is is by
the time you're done loading all the
cost onto it it's surprisingly expensive
um
but if it's a large number of items you
can put that fairly down your priorities
for cost reduction
that is just not true if that person's
carrying one thing
we're well past ocd
in our process design and our floor
design if i can take two seconds out of
the walking around phase of a process i
will re-engineer the the floor to make
that happen
right and we now have a group of people
who have that mindset and are actually
looking for opportunities to take that
out but you really have to be rigorous
about this in a way that manufacturers
talk about and they recognize the
importance of
in the end
but it's still not necessarily the thing
they're obsessed about
um
and
in many cases they actually don't know
where their time is going right they
don't have time in motion studies they
don't actually know where their labor
costs are going and if you don't know
where your costs are going you don't
know how to optimize
so
the assembly part of this stuff right
the printing's easy especially with
modern printers right i can send a
different image to the printer we put it
on whatever we're putting it on right
largely hands-free
um but at some point stuff has to get
put together right and that's done by
humans mostly some of it can be done by
robots but not all of them um
that's where
the big part of the problem is people
get caught up in
pieces of software to do all kinds of
clever automation right and they forget
about this assembly part of the problem
and then when it's all done i've got to
do tracking and rework right
instead of having 10 000 items and if i
if i drop one and i send
9999 to the customer what's the customer
going to do ask me to go back and make
one more
well yeah actually home depot might do
that
right but by and large it's close enough
customer bought one and i lose it that's
the whole order
right and now i've got 9 000 things
going across my floor each of which is
going to a different customer it's
different tracking requirement
and
a speed oddly enough is not always your
friend one of the common errors we have
and there's nothing we can do in our
production process to eliminate this
is customers will call us they'll want a
phone number put in a product
uh sorry not call us they'll go online
they want a phone number put on the
product and they enter nine digits
we don't always control the
customization interface so we're not
always in a position to validate what
they've put in at the point of entering
so we get an order which has a phone
number that's obviously missing a digit
and
we're at the point where from the time
we strip in order to the time we're in
carrier packaging ready to go with that
product it's about six minutes
if the customer doesn't call us the next
15 seconds we're gonna have to remake
the product
or we're gonna figure out some clever
way to figure out what their phone
number should have been which we
occasionally do
right that's not the mindset if i'm if
i'm doing big production right there's
time in there for a validation cycle
that we just don't have
in single piece production
so there's the what are the errors that
i'm making and then there are what are
the errors the input i'm getting that i
can't always control and if i'm under an
outside constraint that says i have to
deliver whether i'm able to talk to the
customer or not the best i can do is
produce and say i'll send you a fixed
one when you get back in touch with me
if you're selling on amazon you have to
ship whether you have the information or
not
that gets a little entertaining
so
in the mass production world there's
this list of things people know that
aren't actually true right one is this
idea that big batches are better
another one is that long lead times are
not only acceptable but normative and
unavoidable
and
i don't want to wait six months for my
product
there's a notion that transportation is
cheap because so much product is moving
that the transportation is well
amortized transportation is not cheap
and i'll come back to that
um i've sort of talked about this i
bought the big machine problem right a
lot of the thinking that goes on this is
not universally true and it's changing
rapidly but a lot of the thinking that
goes on is
how do i maximize
the utilization of this very expensive
piece of equipment that i just bought
partly because i fell in love with the
thing i paid more for it than i should
have now i got to justify my decision
right
um
when what i need to be thinking is how
do i maximize customer value
the closer you get to the customer in
deciding how to do that the better you
are able to do that and there are lots
of barriers between a large producer and
the customer
in those departments
people think
that careers and middlemen reduce risk
well
right actually distributors in a weird
sort of way provide a funding solution
for manufacturers right they buy product
from the manufacturers they store it and
they hopefully catch that it sells
right it's it's in some sense a
financing exercise but ultimately if
that product doesn't sell
the discriminators often have the right
to return it
now what okay transportation is not
cheap it's actually quite expensive
because every transportation step a
moving product from one party to another
party so that the second party can do
something
second party is going to touch the
product they've got to add cost
to pay for whatever it is that they did
right so they're going to add markup and
by and large the markup they're going to
add is 30 at every touch of the product
except for the last step because the
retailer typically wants to make half of
what you pay at the point of retail they
want to make that as
their part of the sale
rule of thumb
um
so if you send a product to a second
party to be plated or finished
you're adding 30
to the cost of the product not because
of the cost of the claiming
right but because of the markup but this
is sort of the
failure of vertical integration in this
particular example right most of the
distribute most of the transportation
steps have to do with inventory and
distributors in the middle these supply
chains as we've seen in the last two
years and this is no surprise to anybody
who actually understood how they work
these supply chains are incredibly
brittle things and if we can get from
where we are now
to doing digital production in a more
localized way where these things are
better integrated and they're happening
local to the customer and they're not
moving around to 15 different parties
um our estimate is that we can get from
11 transportation steps for a part on
average by the time it gets to the
customer to somewhere around six
and all by itself
that reduces the list price of the
product that you see in the store
by 3.7 times
because every transportation step is
adding 30 percent except for the last
one and if we then take out the 30 of
products that are going unsold because
nobody actually
that's another one 1.4 reduction in peg
price right because we have to pay for
those products
and when you add this up this is a
little better than a factor of five do i
think we're going to get to it tomorrow
no way
this will be a gradual transition
but i think we actually can go we think
we can get for a single piece production
we can be producing what the customer
wants and we can do it reducing the
price
which is kind of astonishing because
everybody's been telling us for decades
making money making things one at a time
and with digital production that's just
not true anymore
so as we set up button smith we sort of
started with this notion
right from the beginning
that we were going to do things one at a
time and we were going to do them in the
way the customer told us that they
wanted them done
so we build absolutely everything that
we do on demand actually there's one
product that's an exception of that
and i am desperately looking forward to
the day we can do that one on demand
it's a no equipment to solve the problem
sort of an issue
and it means that for this one product
we carry finished inventory and it makes
me crazy
um
we by and large don't carry finished
inventory there's not one exception
right
um everything we do is flow oriented not
batch oriented it's not that we're not
doing high value high volume right it's
that we're doing volume which is a
series of single pieces
right and we don't want anything
bottlenecking right because then we've
got a pile we've got to clear out to
just waste time
one of the things i've said and it's one
of the reasons in some cases we haven't
always expanded our product capabilities
quickly is if i have a choice between
buying a second printer or having
somebody change the media on a roll
printer i'm going to buy the second
printer because i can't afford to change
the media every day
and that's a crazy mindset from a mass
producer perspective right the mass
producer is all concerned about
amortizing the cost of the changeover my
goal is to get rid of it
we're a union shop
that's
partly about who our customers are but
it's also partly a philosophy decision
we actually believe that our people
matter
uh you know one one of the one of the
first rules we have we laugh about it a
little bit internally but we're serious
is you know
step one is don't kill the company and
step two is don't hurt the employees
we won't run solvent prayers because
they cause neurological damage over over
time we've made the choice that we're
not going to do that
um we're a us-made company right we're
making
money in this process doing it us-made
you can't do that either nobody told us
um
we're set up as direct to customer
because
you can't inventory stuff that is
individuated for each customer it
doesn't make sense
and that means there are all these
stages in the middle that we don't have
that we don't have to pay for and that
the customer doesn't experience delay
waiting for those intermediate steps to
deal with their purchase
and because we started primarily as an
amazon prime seller
one of the very early decisions we made
was to focus on speed
and at the time the way the rules worked
for amazon prime was you know you have a
shipping cut off
and your your same day ship obligation
ends one hour before your shipping cut
off
so
whatever comes over the wall at t minus
61 minutes has to be made and shipped
that day
and we built an entire production
facility to make that possible
and getting it down to
10 minutes per product wasn't that big a
challenge getting it down to eight
minutes for product that was a little
more right now we're at six
and we're at three labor minutes getting
from eight labor minutes to three labor
minutes
it was brutal
right and now we're pushing to do better
but that's where we are
um that's well within the time frame in
which you actually could make the
product
right and ship it same day
unless it comes in at 501 um
or when you're shutting down
so that's what we focused on doing and
in most cases we actually produce
faster than companies can find an
already made product in inventory and
shipping i'm not talking about amazon
they're extraordinary doing this third
about seven seconds and that's really
impressive we're definitely not there
but shippers aren't there most
fulfillment houses aren't anywhere close
to that
we did a lot of automation to do this
because of course there's actual work
that has to happen in this process but a
lot of it is rote work
we started the customer and worked our
way back the very first thing we looked
at automating was how do we take what
the customer's handed us and turn it
into something we can put on the floor
and start production on with as little
human effort as possible and we're about
five seconds of order validation per
order and we're done and the only reason
it's five is because one order in ten
has some error we actually have to go
deal with most of them you take a quick
glance the order's fine you're done you
send it to production you move on to the
next order
and
to work through all this and to make
sure we understood which were the right
problems to solve
we set up a prototype production floor
if you want to build software to do
something new and you don't do that
you're throwing darts at the wall and
you can get lucky
but it's not what you call a robust
business strategy if you know about lean
manufacturing you're by this point
hearing a lot of echoes of lean ideas in
here and and that's right we're pushing
the lean notions kind of to the next
step and lean now is
the original idea is probably 70 years
old and there's some things we can do
better but there's still sound right
there they're very much like john
hennessey's work on quantifying computer
architecture
in some ways
the difference is we're relying much
more heavily on automation which when
toyota started working in the toyota
production system part of the issue was
they just didn't have the capital to do
that early on it's part of why they
invented the lean system
right
we're looking at things that are either
high or low mix because the digital
tooling can go either way
um
people in the lean world talk about
single piece flow and they mean it
but when it actually comes time to
deploy it in a real world large-scale
manufacturer the idea that they're going
to work on single pieces is kind of
unimaginable right so it becomes an
ideal that you move progressively
towards
but it often turns out to be something
you never actually reach
in our case we started doing single
piece throughout flow and we were
absolutely obsessive about maintaining
that
um
in
one of the big ideas in lean and this is
kind of the thing that when you stop and
think about it justifies a lot of the
things that we're doing in mass
production that are kind of problematic
they focused on reducing change over
time
if you if you look at the lean
literature you'll see people talking
about what they call single minute
exchange of dies right it's about
getting from one type of product to the
next product as fast as possible because
every second you spend in the switchover
you're not producing value right and in
the digital world if you're careful
about it you often can get to zero
changeover times right so
that's the secret sauce
right is the software automation
and the fact that zero changeover times
qualitatively alter how we can think
about the product mix
and you can't do that
with the tools with the methods with the
mindset that we've been applying to mass
production
you need digital tooling to do it and
that's mostly not how production is
being done
in most of the world i mean we can talk
about plenty of places that are further
along in this
so what have we developed along the way
to make this actually work
we do our order processing in about five
seconds that requires a whole bunch of
software support we do design for
automation upfront and customization how
is the customer going to customize the
product or tune the product that's part
of our product design process
not just in the what's it going to look
like since but in the how are we going
to produce it since we're to design on
those things all the time we've built a
management engine for doing on-demand
production of these kinds of categorized
products that lets us generate them very
quickly along the way we've done
probably the best virtual product
photography in the world at least that
we know about three weeks from now
that'll be somebody else because that's
how this stuff works um and maybe the
best listing management software in the
world and why are those two things
important um and hard
your designer
had insomnia right and they walked in
this morning with 40 new designs because
that was how they got themselves back to
sleep
those designs can go on 20 to 25
different product form factors that you
have each of which needs a new listing
each of which needs five product
photographs right and you can see these
numbers getting way bigger than a human
can rationally manage
and by the way that was just your desire
right you have all these partners who
are doing the same thing and their
designers couldn't sleep either
right we're often doing
hundreds of new listings in a matter of
hours
and there's nobody else in the world
who's doing that right now
and
for each of those listings we've got to
do product photographs and uh where it
goes out and these are examples right so
there was no
uh per product photography that happened
here right this was the design
getting morphed over the product um it's
a little bit of an unfortunate expensive
very similar kinds of products
and when you step back and look at all
of this the assumption that single piece
production is expensive turns out not to
be right
twice as expensive to make it
the transportation steps down
the end price of the customer is still
lower
right and that's actually very hard to
do in a mass production mindset right
getting rid of the things that are
unsold because we don't make them if
they're unsold is big right and it turns
out it's not
it's 10 to 15 more that you're doing
something wrong from from our point of
view at least right the first is you
think statistical quality control is a
good idea
you're building these things you have
people touching them and lots of steps
along the way
if these people have their eyes open
they should be doing quality control as
the thing moves across their hands
what were they doing
right why do i now need some inspection
station later to make sure that it all
went well
if my people are doing the right steps
and actually thinking about their work
as they're doing it i mean there's
there's there's a question to be asked
here right
um
in our view you're doing something wrong
if things stack up because that means
that you've got an impedance mismatch
between one stage of your production in
the next stage
fix the production process don't figure
out how to build stacks of things
you're probably doing something wrong if
you're tempted by job shop scheduling
software right the reason we have job
shop scheduling software is that we have
big jobs and we have little jobs and we
have to find a mix in which our
customers are satisfied and we don't
stop using the equipment
maybe the answer to that is not to have
big jobs
right when all the jobs are one piece
the job shop scheduling problem goes
away i saw some beautiful software
yesterday to track and manage this kind
of an issue
and the poor person i was talking to
became very frustrated
because
we don't have this problem and it's not
that i don't want to track things it's
that my motivation for tracking things
is very different than the problem the
software is trying to solve
if you're looking at job shop scheduling
look at your production processes
because something's wrong
um
here's a big one you're making a mistake
if you make something before it's paid
for
that's huge
right
i think there's a real possibility that
we can get digital production to a
negative cash conversion cycle at which
point the more you make the more money
you make the more you're able to grow
we're not there yet
and i have to qualify that right because
there's an initial fill on parts and
you're going to have to do that ahead of
time so we're not strictly in the way
negative cash conversion is described
right but that's possible here because
the process is so fast and you don't
have all of these artificial delays
built into it
um
you know in deadline and i guess i'm
kind of back to the job shop thing right
if my deadline isn't now the right
question is why not
what am i doing then i can't produce
these things
you know with the view that everything
has to be done now
now
if i'm doing furniture yeah there's a
three-day curing process on my finish
that i have to do at the end and i can i
can't take that out right so it's not
it's not that there's any magic here
that lets me declare things to be done
before they're done
right but conceptually
my goal should at least be let me get
the product into the curing stage and
then i'll have it sit for three days
before i ship it but in some sense i'm
done right i've got the shipping step
left to do
right but i'm not going to wait for
another thousand units to be made before
me to talk about you
even elon can do this i love picking on
a lot because he's you know he's so
bigger than life
in a sense
tesla is collecting payment before they
start producing they're not collecting
the whole cost of the car right but you
do have to put in an initial amount to
get your reservation done and there's a
psychology of commitment there in some
sense they know you're going to pay
before you actually before they actually
make the car right
the model 3 right now takes 10 hours
from the time the order goes in to the
time the car is off of the production
process
that's
awe-inspiring and it's one of the things
about tesla that i think is
under-appreciated media is how
successful they've been
at automating and tuning and reducing
their production costs it's really
stunning um you know the
full self drive gets all the attention
right but but this is one of the big
things that they've done right in the
sense they're doing local production
right they're standing on production
facilities nationally
it's it's not at the scale of you know
your local shopping mall
but at least in principle
they could do 48 hour delivery on every
vehicle they sell
made in that 48 hours and delivered by
the time those 48 hours are over they'd
have to stand up a few more production
facilities but not very many
um wherever they can they're using local
suppliers which eliminates or reduces
their supply chain vulnerabilities right
they're doing continuous improvement
right they're wrong they make changes on
the vehicle continuously there's no
notion of a model year
um
okay
uh i'm running out of time so i want to
i want to
do some of these selectively i've
already talked about the nine digit
problem uh one of the things you'll find
if you if you go to like a printing
trade show is people will talk to you
about keeping track of your ink costs
and i got to tell you if you can find
your ink costs in the production you're
doing really well that's about the last
thing you need to look at
um i've talked about the cost of walking
around so maybe i don't need to come
back to that but but here's one right
and this is sort of about how do you
think about about product design right
why can't you buy pre-addressed wedding
invitations at any sort of reasonable
cost
a digital press could do that
the reason the digital press doesn't do
that is you have to unfold the flaps to
run them through the digital press and
unfolding the flaps takes a human right
and the labor time makes the cost
prohibitive
so why are the flaps folded
the flaps are folded because
behind your distributor there was an
envelope converter and the envelope
converter has this practice of folding
the flaps before they put them in the
box
so when does the flap get folded turns
out it's the very last step in
production in the envelope they only
need to turn it off and put them in a
different size box
and then you can print
individually addressed wedding
invitations
why isn't it being done because nobody's
thought across the process chain to ask
why this step is being done in this way
and could it be done in a different way
i talked about the palette issue with
with ebsco you know sort of a related
discussion with hp at the time we were
looking at how do we print chloroplasts
on two sides and hp saying we'll run it
through the machine and bring it down or
back around the front of the machine and
turn it turn it over and run it through
on the back side i'm like i don't want
to pay somebody to run around feeding
things to machines that's not value
what i want is a robot arm and i'm going
to run the first side through one
machine and i'm going to put a second
machine at the output of the first
machine and i'm going to have a robot
arm take the coroplast off the first
machine turn it over put it on the
second machine and we'll just do the
whole thing linearly
and then we'll feed it into the cutter
right this is the flow idea i don't want
to stack this stuff up and finish it
later i want to get it through and get
it done
and and this was a sort of an
interesting conversation from the
perspective of the hp people for two
reasons one nobody actually pointed out
to them that this was possible and the
second and this is sort of internal
politics at work this sort of thing
never happened at ibm
there are bigger divisions that think
they own the palletizing problem right
these are the mid-size printers and they
kind of like the idea that they would
get to offer a capability that the the
grand printers don't offer right it's
sort of an internal you know ego battle
about one division's products versus
another so the idea that they can do
this is kind of kind of fun
this last story though is worth telling
so
when covet hit
we actually were on top of it pretty
early we went into quarantine at the end
of january
in that first year
and of course in the state of washington
businesses went through a mandatory
shutdown
um and we realized that we had the
capability to do masks by the time it
was all done we were consuming 85 of the
output of one of the major us textile
producers we sold a lot of masks of
course haynes decided to do that too
levi's decided to do that too and they
started actually at about the same time
that we did with their designs
and they did what they always do right
they come up with a mass design and they
send it to honduras to have it
manufactured
and three to four months later the first
cardio container is full of masks come
back
now we did an initial mass design that
was frankly pretty conservative it was
pretty conventional we started getting
feedback from customers the mask would
be better if it did this
could we get a filter pocket
sure we added a filter pocket
could we find a way to make the masks
adjustable so that they fit better yep
we did adjustable masks pretty much
every adjustable mask that you see out
there right now that's a cotton mask is
a clone of our adjustable desk
can we make masks that are sized for
children
sure we can do that
and the reason we could do all of those
things was we didn't have a huge
commitment to fixed inventory that we
had to worry about abandoning
by the time those products came back
from honduras for haynes we had done
four design turns responding to the
market
you can't do that
if you're producing a million of them at
a time and hoping the things will sell
it just doesn't work
and by the way you also can't keep your
long tail value
we have probably the most dog collar
designs in simultaneous production of
any company in the world and because we
do them one at a time it costs us
nothing to keep a slow moving design
in you know in stock figuratively
speaking that is able to be made on
demand turns out
that's ten percent of your revenue and
the reason nobody can tell you that is
nobody's in the position to try it
but it actually matters
okay so putting this all together um and
i probably need to need to stop pretty
soon uh dennis because we we should
respect people's time so buttons has
managed to grow about 85 a year for the
last seven years um we've done it mostly
organically i personally put some money
into the business but that up until now
is the only outside investment we've
taken
there have been years in which we've run
substantially more than that we had a
500 year and that's great on the one
hand and it's also the kind of growth
that can kill your company if you're not
prepared for it
um
we continue to have a per capita revenue
that's higher than microsoft
that's crazy we're a manufacturer not a
software producer
um
average units program i mean i talked
about us doing single piece production
right in the 600 000 orders that we had
before we started making cobit mess the
average order was 1.04 things that's as
close to one piece production as you
really get in the real world there's
always somebody who orders two of
something right so you never get through
one
i've talked about the numbers on our our
production times um this is producing
something that we've potentially never
seen before
we've seen dog collars before but we
don't know how this stock collar is
going to be done
and if i take out the errors that arise
because the customer handed us bad data
which is not something we're in a
position really to fix most most of the
time
our rework is substantially below half
percent actually closer to 0.03 the last
time i measured
which is crazy
the mass producers often have rework
rates much higher than that
and partly it's because we're looking at
everything as it goes by
okay so uh let me open up the questions
and also for for anybody who's
um at stanford who i can't see maybe in
the classroom um
uh if i don't manage to get to questions
feel free to reach out we've got a a
mailing address we've set up and send
your questions and i'll i'll do my best
to get them answered for you
um so questions about this has been a
long talk and i apologize but
well i guess i'm going to be
the first person here and just ask that
we need use no names
because that keeps the uh the video
clean
uh and then i would question john are
you going to be in the business of
making plants
of making plants yes manufacturing
facilities
in an indirect sense yes
ultimately
i think we would prefer not to be in the
production business at all right our
goal is to do the software issues around
the production because frankly there are
people who know a lot more about
production than we do
that said
this is not the kind of production that
they have an enormous amount of
experience with right and that issue of
how do we get to the right combination
of hardware modularity and software
modularity process modularity
that's new territory
and we're going to have to prove out
those techniques and then we're going to
have to make them available to producers
for reasons i've articulated that's
going to be a slow process there's going
to be resistance to change and and not
because people are resistant but because
it's actually really hard both
conceptually and financially
hopefully we will see new people coming
into this marketplace who are willing to
try something different
but i think frankly we're going to have
to stand up more production facilities
while that's happening
um and the more successful we are at
that the more it's going to be difficult
to sell what we're doing because we'll
end up competing with our with our
customers then we'll have to back off we
have to navigate that process one way or
another how it's going to play out is
very hard to know in advance
okay
what kinds of questions what kinds of
products are you talking about
you're thinking about making other than
you know buttons business cards and dog
collars good question
so we started in what might be
characterized as sort of promotional
kinds of products
um because it was the low hanging point
of entry into this space right it's it's
relatively speaking pretty easy to do it
only took us six years to get all of
that working
um
but now we've got all this
infrastructure working and actually i
was talking uh yesterday
with several different companies who are
in one form or another of of 3d
production or specialty production
we will move into those spaces hp has
done some really interesting work
in reducing the cost of
of plastic printing
uh 3d printing um now there's a whole
process that their stuff has to go
through to be something that you're
going to hand to a customer
but it's the cheapest by far of probably
cost per unit basis of anything that
you've we've seen of course
it's the quarter million dollar printer
so you're not going to buy one for your
basement
um
but that's a whole new class of products
that we can optimize for customers
according to customer need
and curiously it's a it's a it's a
family of opportunities where now i have
all these people who bought this quarter
million dollar printer and they need to
pay for it
um so we're definitely moving in that
direction but i think that uh the 3d
is
the next place that we're going um give
me multiple process steps
yeah
so one of the questions that got asked
the very very first year we went to
what's now printing united
um they run
panels right and people ask questions
and one person in the audience said hey
i'm opening up a new print shop how do i
remain
competitive with the print shop down the
street
and the answer that came back from the
panel i thought was was insightful the
the person on the panel said do
something that involves at least two
steps because the likelihood that you
and your competitor can do the same two
steps is actually pretty low more steps
you put in the more true that is right
and so now you're differentiated because
you can do something that they can't and
probably vice versa
right um
these uh the hp products actually have
this property
because of the extra steps that they
have to do so we are very very
definitely moving
from doing things that i think you could
characterize as 2d maybe two and a half
d in some cases
into 3d i don't i don't see us doing
that this year i think our big challenge
this year is dealing with some of the
soft materials
um dealing with automation around that
but we're definitely going there
well but your products are all
things that
are needed rapidly to make any to be
worth it to the customer
i'm trying to think of high value
products that need to be
available quickly and the only thing i
can come up with is things involving
dentistry
there's actually a huge business there
it turns out yeah i know in fact the
largest just-in-time manufacturer i know
of is invisalign which makes those
3d
yeah and they have a really interesting
process behind
there's a
and i apologize for framing it there's a
generational thing going on right my
father can't understand
why getting things in two days matters
right he just doesn't feel that sense of
urgency
right
but amazon has trained a huge customer
base to think that two days is the
criteria for success whether they
actually need it in two days or not is
irrelevant
they think they need two days
and that makes it a customer requirement
and for a long time it was why people
bought from amazon
now
i think amazon is putting that process
at risk right now
if you can get your car in two days will
that change who you buy your car from
and the the evidence would suggest
that the turnaround that tesla's been
able to produce actually matters well i
mean so here's an example a new phone
comes out
and it doesn't have accessories until
three months after it's been shipped
uh the macbook pro 14 inch came out you
couldn't get a case
for
three months
you could get the machine but not the
case
so i'm sure there are other examples of
cases where rapid manufacturing
would have a big market
but i'm
not coming up with the products quite
yet
how about how about pastries in a
restaurant
pastries or other people are doing
custom pancake printing
did you know that
birthday cakes
uh here's a a an example that's just a
little
it's adjacent to the one that you get
with the phones right
why can't you get a playstation right
now
good question
right are there people who would buy
that
if it could be produced locally
you bet
i mean right now the the gray market if
you will in those devices people are
paying four or five times less price of
devices to get them
now and that's a pretty good calibration
of the perception of urgency
and and as to um the the the cases and
things like that so what's the issue
with the cases why why does it take
three months i mean the device comes
down right my designer sits down and
designs a case that's not a multi-month
process that's a day or two
why does it take three months because i
have to do the mass production and fill
the pipeline
so my answer to that is get rid of the
pipeline
so john if that's the case uh
what sort of a material supply line do
you have for the
the local small volume
special device manufacturing
it's a great question and we were
actually talking to people at hp about
this just yesterday um
so i think right now our material supply
at least mostly takes the form of parts
but going forward i think as we
integrate vertically
more and more that will drive down
towards raw materials when i when i look
at my physical inventory space for all
the parts we have
i've got two vendors who account for 60
of my physical inventory money the
reason they account for 60 of my
physical inventory volume is they're
unpredictable and i have to buffer
to deal with their unpredictability
and there's one of them that i would
give several teeth to remove from my
supply chain because they're so
unpredictable and hp may have just given
me a way to do it
and the cool part about that is
the hp device it's not as fast as
injection molding
no way
right
but i don't need a million parts a day
i need the parts i'm going to consume in
the next 24 hours if i'm taking that
approach right that's a different
problem statement
maybe i do it a week at a time right but
i don't have the same carrying costs
right and the input material at that
point becomes the filament or the
deposition powder or whatever it turns
out to be and it's not that i'm eager to
move away
from these parts suppliers they often
have really valuable expertise that i
don't have
um
could learn maybe but you know there's a
hundred thousand things that i could
usually learn next i gotta make choices
when i have a supplier in the way
right i'm going to try to vertically
integrate them out of the picture
because
they're in my way
so i think as that happens progressively
we're going to see a move towards closer
to closer and closer to raw materials
well do you think john that you've just
opened up the can of worms here and uh
have
maybe launched a change in the total way
in which we perceive manufacturing
well i think we'll know in 10 years but
i hope so i hope we learned it sooner
than that
10 years is a long way out these days
but um dennis for you will make it
happen faster okay that's good can you
get it finished in five
we'll do our best how about you know i
don't i don't know there's learning
curve here there are things that we
don't know
worst or things that we don't know that
we don't know
and we're going to have to work our way
through it right that's where that's why
there is this prototyping facility and
we're going to we're going to hit
roadblocks we're going to hit surprises
but um
i i can i can speculate with some
confidence that this year will not be
one of the 85 years we'll do a good bit
better than that this year
okay and i'm a little feeling a little
cautious about saying how we're going to
do that right now
um it's because of a new product line
that we're watching that that matters
that's time sensitivity
well we're running up out of time does
there any other question
okay
well john thank you very much it was
i think i think uh
of the
380 talks that i've had something to do
with which were a few
uh this is one of the more
more significant i think in uh five
years time we'll go back and look at it
and we'll say ah that was the beginning
so i think i think you've hit on a
really
very significant point
and i really appreciate you giving us
the opportunity to hear what you have to
say you are
gracious as always and i still owe you
um that modular robotics talk with
everyone oh that's fine that you will
we'll se we'll set you up on that
and uh but thank you for this this this
is uh at least given me a great deal to
think about and i i think it's really
good um i do want to point out that you
um
uh your choice of the name button smith
makes sense on the one end you push a
button to get something done and of
course smith makes so you know how you
picked that name i don't know
you know it's funny it did make sense
when we started and of course you can do
a retcon right tell the story like you
told now um but explaining to investors
that you're not actually a manufacturer
which is a requirement if you want them
to invest
gets a little tricky when your name is
buttonsmith and so what i think is
actually going to happen
is that we will push into a new name
that's not bound in some people's heads
to manufacturing um and then we'll look
at some restructuring so it's easier to
see that we're a software company it's a
perception problem um but perception is
real it's important
that's true
anyhow thank you very much and we'll
we'll certainly be watching what uh what
goes on here thank you
take care thank you all bye-bye